[Music]
foreign
get it drew oh I mean Megan the switch
is on Drew Barrymore Taps into her
horror Roots by channeling Megan from
the hit film about a lifestyle's robotic
doll equipped with AI that turns deadly
you watch scary movies and it's like
damn when they're good you got to give
credit to the people who are doing it
because they're hard you know they're
hard to make it real and look good
without acting the talk show host is in
full costume as she shares her
impersonation of the character and a
clip posted to her Show's Instagram
account on Tuesday
Megan
and our co-host Ross Matthew plays Along
by mimicking Megan's on-screen owner
Katie in the film Hi Megan I'm Katie
it's nice to meet you Katie do you want
to hang out but you can't be Megan
without her iconic dance moves that went
viral before the movie even premiered
and Drew does not disappoint
hi
[Music]
yes to the illusion of a cartwheel Nelda
Drew thank you the video was captioned
quote Megan has taken over the Drew
Barrymore show and it's for good reason
Drew dressed up to surprise guest
Allison Williams who stars in Megan and
boy does she put Drew's Megan abilities
to the test number one rule if you are a
true Megan is can you run but on all
fours well I don't know you programmed
me
see if I can okay
you're a natural this was another level
that's commitment love to see it
something else that's another level
Megan's success it's unreal since its
Premiere Megan's made more than 100
million dollars at the box office and
the sequel is in the works
she's the definition okay Megan's
plastic foot is on my neck Megan's high
profile success has also made its mark
on Studio 8h this weekend Allison made a
cameo on Saturday Night Live and a
parody of the film with host Aubry Plaza
starring as Megan 2.0 I'm bored drive me
home
Megan you messy hoe I'm obsessed with
you everyone stop get away from her she
is not your friend she's a killer and
she will kill you not an empty threat
with her E.T spoke with Allison at the
film's premiere in December which
featured a horde of Megan dolls dancing
on the red carpet
awesome it's just
honestly we you know you make a movie
you come up with the marketing campaign
and you just hope it like takes off you
hope it resonates but you have no idea
what's gonna happen like there's no way
to predict anything in this business and
then once we started seeing people
reacting to it on Twitter we were like
oh this is the best case scenario people
are having so much fun with her they
seem to understand like what her energy
was which was the best like she's a very
specific Vibe very specific kind of gal
or Megan and we knew that the mission
was as long as people like understood
her we were gonna be okay and so yeah
[Music]
foreign